taking time to have small chats about
nothing in particular with people we
don't know and are unlikely ever to meet
again can from some perspectives seem
like the height of absurdity maybe we're
in a coffee shop and someone's preparing
us a drink perhaps we've crossed the
neighbor in the hallway while getting
our post or we're on a train waiting for
the doors to open why would we bother to
hold up our day for a few moments given
how many things we already need to do
and how many good friends we already
have that we haven't seen in far too
long we may also have a more high-minded
defense for our silence we aspire to be
profound people and there is no way that
we can get anywhere meaningful with a
near or complete stranger in a
compressed amount of time we shun the
smaller chats because in the back of our
minds we tell ourselves that we are
already sufficiently deeply committed to
the long and consequential ones
but this is to miss the point and the
opportunities presented by minor social
exchanges they stand in relation to
lengthy friendships rather as haikus do
next a thousand page novels there are
things a tiny poem can do that a
comprehensive narrative will miss there
are single sentences that can Mark us as
much as entire volumes there are
pictures that can stick with us in a way
that a three-hour film won't
we can be disproportionately and yet
powerfully touched by so-called minor
things small sympathetic chats matter
Above All Because few of us are ever
very far from sadness and despondency
there are so many reasons to dislike
ourselves to be paranoid about what
other people think and to regret
mistakes we've made when we are in a
febrile or fragile mood a short kindly
exchange can be all that's needed to
start to turn around a deeply Dark Day
an enormous amount of sympathy and
fellow feeling can be compressed in the
most minuscule dialogue they make them
like that to torture us don't they we
might say to a parent struggling to
close the zip on a child's jacket in a
sudden downpour thereby sending a modest
sign that we know how difficult things
can be and that we have in some ways
being there or somewhere like there
ourselves
or we might on our way to a station
exchange one or two sympathetic words
with a taxi driver about their elderly
mother who we learn has just gone into a
care home after having a fall the chat
won't change anything in an already
tricky situation but the humanity on
display might just
the philosopher Arthur schopenhauer
remarked that we can never know for sure
who around us may at any particular
moment be thinking of ending their own
life the thought usefully puts into
relief what might be at stake in any
exchange we may at points and without
any obvious warning be the last thing
between someone and their decision to
despair
a charge often made against small chats
is that we can surely only be pretending
to be friendly yet this is to miss out
how much and How Deeply our hearts may
go out to people whose lives we merely
brush against
we can imagine our way into pains whose
details we will never know we can if it
doesn't sound too paradoxical love a
stranger
and even more oddly for only a minute or
two
we are in all this so often held back by
unhelpfully Grand ideas of what it means
to change the world we imagine the
requirements for improvement on such a
large scale that along the way we end up
grievously neglecting what it is
actually in our powers to achieve right
now today the next time we go out we
suffer from an upside down view of where
significance can lie we are assembled
out of small things and may live or die
by their presence or absence
we have in our hands a very potent
weapon already the power to say a warm
gentle sympathetic hello